Webster's dictionary defines insanity as
reading the youtube comments
however I do it every now and again yet
we try to monitor what's going on who
want to get into what you guys
are thinking and you know every now and
again the
we get some some real hate on Sunday we
lead them and you know I come to get
somebody like what I think mostly we
actually get good stuff which is
actually incredibly nice
cuz if you guys are watching this on you
do you know how the comment section can
be but generally
people seem to dig what we're doing and
I thought we pull out a couple comments
from
videos we've done over the past couple
weeks talk about toppers we did a video
two weeks ago about how I Elton John
had said that geez is would love gay
people
are to hear the comment from sunny on
that video he said hey they just because
Jesus loves gays doesn't mean he
accepted your homosexual lifestyle
flash behavior G then love the sinner
but he
within tiny have been to have to beg to
differ with you on this one
I first I don't live my life by a lie
and Saurabh
rules but my own and I i think I've said
from the San moral parameters
for my life and I don't think there
there's a a magical guy
in the sky judging me as I find that I
don't think I'd playing dice
with the universe and just watching us
in judging I say he's probably got
better things to do
if he exists at all and so I'm really
does not concern the G's is
watching and worrying about my sex life
but
thank you for your concern and I hope
you're having their some fun in that
okay we did a video about how people
don't trust mainstream news which was
actually one of my favorite things we've
done recently
because yeah mainstream news is terrible
and that's why we do
what we do here and this person was
referencing a video
that we showed a couple months back this
is
on Andrea Mitchell reports on MSNBC
she's talking about the NSA with the
congress one then and then watch what
happens
I think at this point we should but
seriously consider
got not shiite not can come into meeting
let me and get an issue
congressman let me interrupt you just
from I'm we've got some breaking news at
Miami
standby coming out right now in Miami
justin Bieber has been arrested on a
number of charges the tragedy
TG reading the charges are low including
resisting arrest and driving under the
influence is appearing now before the
judge for his bond hearing let's watch
soap and 211 commented
don't forget about interrupting a
serious discussion with someone for
breaking news about Justin Bieber and
Kris Jenner because Lord knows we care
about them so that obviously the clip
that he was referencing yes
this is exactly what is wrong with
mainstream news you know the beauty
about what we do on you too and not just
not just us and not just breeze but you
select what you want to watch so we put
up
we try to put up seven videos per week
and guess what you don't like the topic
you don't click it and that it and it's
a simple as that but with these
mainstream news organizations they're
selecting what they're giving you
and you don't know when it's coming up
and because a bad
they can give you for example CNN three
months a plane coverage which got no
resolution and then we're speculating
the entire time
or MSNBC talking about the NSAA
the NSAA and breaking into Justin Bieber
going to court and it by a truck by this
like the my new show up court details
is beyond ridiculous to forget even
Bieber in this but whenever they show
some poor thing about
you know a murder some horrific thing
when they're showing you look what's
happening in the court
there's nothing more dribble iz than
that and then of course you throw in
Bieber
so the problem is that the mainstream
media is drippin by
ratings now course we want you guys to
click this every week I want our cliques
to go up interviews to go up and they
are going up we've doubled since
September it all work in
I and that's the beauty I love you too
and that's the beauty of
why people are coming to to online news
sources instead mainstream news
pretty great we need me a couple weeks
ago on what is this porno sexual
I the guy who coined the phrase metro
sexual
says that metro sexual czar passe ass
porno sexual
are these guys straight guys who are
obsessed with their bodies are muscles
and tattoos
and it's not just about looking good in
the bath the clothes anymore in 30 David
Beckham's
it's more of a combination of porn and
you know self be image so Booster Gold
had this to say:
in what world was the only gay men who
had good physiques I know plenty of fat
stick then an average body gay guys and
I know plenty amazingly in shape
heterosexual men both athlete and just
guys who spent a lotta
time at the gym now he's referencing a
comment I a joke about how sport a
sexual are
straight guys just becoming gay now the
West I would which is why you know like
a gay Mecca
and they're just guys with huge muscles
walking around all the time and they're
always going to the gym no matter what
time it is there always going to the
game
if you leave the gym but there are going
to the game and they have huge muscles a
little dogs your bicep
should not be bigger than your ops a
lobster I am
and so yes there are all kinds
gay guys I don't have a perfectly tight
six pack their
I said it let the judgment again I am in
a course there are
there are perfectly in shape straight
guys in there outta shape gay guys in
there everything in between that's what
makes
the world go around but yes but every
community does have a different thing
about body image and I think
the gay community is different issue
about body image than the street me as
but some of it all kinda blending and
that's progress when we all realize that
ultimately we're really just the thing
and finally we did a video a couple
weeks ago on conspiracy theories and we
were quoting some info that
a tremendous amount Americans actually
do believe in conspiracy theories
and we got a comment here from Daniel
bloom he said I like to read into
conspiracy theories but without a
hundred percent
evidence I won't say there are 100
percent true like Bill Maher says in
really good with
what I'm presenting is dow when I read
and see how much more federal government
has lied to us and usually so they can
get more money in their pockets
and then to see how much and how many
people have benefited from the war in
Iraq
you can't help but wonder yeah I
often quote Bill Maher who is a a major
influence have mine I
you know want the comment that I made in
that video was cross a guy who said
extraordinary claims
require extraordinary evidence and party
thing with conspiracy theories is their
conspiracy theories because they can
be proven to you can have a lot evidence
that you know the government was a 980
buyer or lyndon johnson was in on it and
the JFK assassination
or you can believe in aliens or whatever
you think you saw it what you think was
an alien but unless you have evidence
then obviously you know not that many
people
are gonna believe it I am so I skied I
believe so many things I don't think
we're poor Brian our own
in the universe I think the day I
gaining a problem probably
did happen I am but ultimately you need
evidence
for all these things and but that you
know thinking about all the things in
speculating what but the truth really is
a were correct about for many years
and and its bite it's fun to think about
and it's fun to talk about
and also makes you feel not that alone
cuz yet we're not getting
just the the truth all the time from
whatever source you're watching
you're not getting a tweet from all the
time thinking about the thing and
talking about them to the Validate
you're crazy thoughts to you is a lot of
fun and anything about I think this was
totally fine and we will do this again
we'll keep watching the you to comment
and the you know so you keep liking and
sharing and doing all that a
and that that thanks for watching